-Hi, Demi. How are you?
-I'm good, Seth.
-I like that we're both showing
off our beautiful stonework.
[ Laughs ]
-Yes.
-How have you been holding up?
-I would say I feel so grateful
that, all considered,
I'm holding up very well.
I'm grateful
to be out of the bigger cities
and out in small-town America
of Idaho,
where I raised my kids.
And it's so beautiful
to look outside every day.
So, yes.
-Counting blessings. You --
I know you're spending the time
with your three daughters.
And how have they enjoyed
the extra time with you?
I feel like parents
really appreciate it.
I'm wondering how the kids feel.
-I think that they have
equally appreciated --
You know, they're -- They
kind of have come in and out,
but a real testament
is their desire to get back here
even when they've had to go back
to do some work,
to all be together.
And, you know,
that is really the gift
in, you know, the challenge,
is this quality time.
And it's a great opportunity
to work on stuff,
because stuff is definitely
going to come up
when you're all this close
together for so long.
-That is very true.
But it strikes me that --
I mean, I have a 2-year-old
and a 4-year-old,
and I am so enjoying it.
We also have our dog.
And our dog --
I think dogs can, you know,
obviously sense your stress.
And I think we're all
a little bit stressed out
because of the time
we're living in.
And so our dog has been acting
a little squirrelly.
But you have how many dogs
in the house right now?
Be honest, Demi.
-Okay. So, I personally
have seven.
Each of my daughters
have one or two pets.
I have someone
who works with me,
who's been working with me
for 27 years,
who also brings a pet.
My aunt is visiting.
She has a dog.
I mean --
-How do the dogs --
Are the dogs cohabiting well?
Because I feel like
we're spending a lot of time
talking about how family members
are getting through this time
being under one roof.
How do the dogs handle it?
-Look, I think for dogs in
general, their owners are home.
They're getting more time
with them.
You know, mine -- You know,
I have a lot of rescues,
which, you know, I feel lucky
that I can actually
take on this many.
And in that grouping
is an entire litter of four.
And so they're all --
-Oh, wow.
-So, I have three.
My aunt has one.
So they're loving it.
They're, like, living
their best lives, truly.
And, you know --
Oh, but a 2- and a 4-year-old.
You guys are, like, on it.
-Yeah.
-That's, like, full-on
entertainment.
Like, you --
-It's good --
Yeah, they definitely require
a lot of our attention.
But it's been really -- I mean,
especially with the 2-year-old,
you know, each day
feels like a lifetime,
because they are just
a different person
at the end of 24 hours.
And because, you know,
ultimately
they have so much more
of my attention,
just because I'm working,
my hours are better,
it's been really cool
to, like, watch them,
I don't know, grow up.
-Amazing. I mean, I really think
that is an incredible gift
and something that I feel a lot
of people are gaining from this,
which is things
that they can do at home
that they didn't
realize they could.
And I think, you know, wherever
this goes and whatever happens,
I do think that there is going
to be some permanent change
in our perception of what we do
and how we do it.
-It's very true --
just in general,
like, what is worth valuing
and what is worth trying
to minimize in our lives.
I want to ask this
because you received,
I guess, some attention,
is the right way
of putting this.
Someone noted online
maybe some design touches
that people would not have
expected from any human being.
We're going to show the photo,
but I think the thing
that was most jarring
was that you have carpeting
in your bathroom.
-Okay. So --
Which is interesting,
which actually, because
this is the house,
again, that my children
grew up in,
and that originally
was a Bruce Willis choice.
-Okay.
-So, not to put it off on him.
We also live in the mountains
where it gets very cold.
So it's never bothered me.
It's actually quite good.
We put rugs in our bathroom.
-Yep. That's true.
-But I appreciate the interest
that has gone into
all of my little oddities,
because this, you know --
this place
definitely houses
a lot of my treasures.
And I have had some big laughs
over the comments
with my family who know me well,
of all of my eccentricities
of small and large,
you know, like
my giant tennis ball.
-Right, a very helpful thing
to have around the house.
-Everyone should have one.
-[ Laughs ]
-I highly recommend.
My giant safety pin.
-Yep. Those are very --
They're great.
-But let me --
I want to point out one thing.
In all of the comments,
I was most disappointed
that nobody commented that
the couch that was in there,
which I am sitting on right now,
is a miniature couch.
-Oh, so, this is fascinating.
I didn't realize you're actually
on the couch right now.
So that means that behind --
Where I am right now
is basically where the bathtub
is, correct?
-Well, no, 'cause the couch
is not normally in my bathroom.
-Oh, that makes me feel better,
'cause the couch being there
also seemed weird.
-I had to move all that in
because, you know,
we were doing this podcast
that we're here to talk about,
and we had to find the place
for the best sound.
-Yes.
-So, I did a test in my closet.
I did in various places.
What came back is that
the bathroom had the best sound.
So, I was in there
for many hours a day.
But I didn't want to --
I couldn't bring
full-size furniture in.
So, this little miniature couch
was something that I had made
for my children long ago.
And so I just whipped this baby
in there.
-That's fantastic. So, giant
tennis balls, tiny couches --
That's basically
how you're living your life.
-There you go.